طريق ملتفه تعتمدها موسكو لنقل نفطها عبر
اسطول الظل الذي يضم اكثر من 100 ناقله
تفتقل لوثائق التامين على الشحن بسبب
العقوبات الغربيه نقلات نفطيه يتجاوز
عمرها 15 عاما منها الناقله توربا التي
تبحر تحت عالم الدوله ذات المكانه الضعيفه
للاشراف على السلامه البحريه وهي
الكاميرون وتقوم بنقل الملايين من براميل
النفط دون تامين مناسب حيث كشف تقرير صادر
عن صحيفه ذئبس بان استمرار موسكو باستخدام
هذا النوع من السفن القديمه التي لا يتم
فحصها وصيانتها بشكل صحيح ينطوي على اخطار
بيئيه كبيره قد تتسبب في اسوا تسربات
للنفط في التاريخ الاوروبي ما لا يقل عن
اربعين سفينه قديمه ابحرت لالاف الاميال
من ميناء سان بطرسبرجر الروسي وقامت بنقل
النف الى الصين والهند وتركيا بين اوائل
ديسمبر واوائل فبراير الماضي كما تقوم بعض
السفن بنقل حمولاتها الخطيره في اعالي
البحار في المياه الدوليه قباله اليونان
او معبر السبت الاسباني شمال افريقيا وهي
مخاطره ضخمه تهدد الملاحه البحريه
الاوروبيه والعالميه خصوصا وان ناقله
توربا فقط نقلت مؤخرا الاورال درجه الخامه
الروسيه الرئيسيه الى الهند واذا ابحرت
الى اسيا فستتضمن الابحار في بحر البلطيق
وعبور العديد من السواحل الاوروبيه رحله
الوقود الروسي وفق تقرير سابق لفايناشن
تايمز كانت تبدا من محطه تكرير تابعه
لعملاق النفط الروسي لوك اويل في جزيره
صقليه الايطاليه وهي التي سمحت لروسيا
بتحقيق مكاسب ماديه حتى بعد فرض العقوبات